[موسيقى]
صراعات باشكال متعدده تحرق الاخضر واليابس
تاركه وراءها غابات ما عادت موجوده سوى
على الورق انهارا يسري فيها الجفاف وحدودا
لا يعبرها احد هذا ارث التقدم والحروب وهو
موضوع هذا المعرض الفني الذي يقيمه معهد
الشرق الاوسط هنا في واشنطن تحت عنوان
ايقاعات محسوسه وازمنه بديله
[موسيقى]
لايجاد طرق جديده للتواصل والعنايه
بالبيئه ومواجهه الاحتباس الحراري وتاثيره
وكل ما تواجهه البشريه اليوم بشكل عام لكن
المقاربه هنا هي على المستوى الشخصي من
خلال النظر الى الايقاعات المختلفه على
سبيل المثال تغيير قاع النهر وتدفقه وتغير
الاشجار البعض منهم يتعامل مع تاريخ عميق
من الصراع والاستعمار والهجره القصريه
بينما يتعامل البعض الاخر مع التجربه
اليوميه
[موسيقى]
نحن نفهم على المستوى العالمي حاله
الطوارئ المناخيه وما يحدث حولنا من ازمات
تقول الخليل لكن الفنانين يسعون الى كشف
ما يعنيه ذلك على المستوى الشخصي وعلاقه
الفرد بالبيئه
هذا حال سكان الاسكندريه حين تعثر نسيمها
بغبار مصنع اسمنت ظل يتوسع حتى غطت سحابته
السامه 60 الف شخص
هذه نباتات كانت تحيا في دجله قبل
اختفائها
وهذه اشجار بيروتيه يشهد تغييرها على
تاريخ المدينه
ومن جبال الامارات يذكرنا النحل بان نوازن
بين ما نستعيره من الثقافات وارسنا
المعرفي يرى المنظمون ان هذه الاعمال توثق
ما يدور حولنا وتؤسس لوعي سياسي يجبرنا
على ايجاد سبل بديله للتناغم مع بيئتنا
والتعايش مع ايقاعات الطبيعه
لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم واشنطن
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات